gonna get a clap seek from back
excellent bike and we go live in three
two
my name is andy roth and i am a
journalist on assignment with national
geographic my name is melissa marquez
i'm a shark scientist the board of the
ocean explorer
and like melissa said we are aboard the
ocean explorer which is a huge vessel
dedicated to science and media
production right now we're in mission
control watching a remotely operated
vehicle descending down to uh what have
we got uh
how do you breathe
231 meters and we are watching two
submersibles that are already down the
bottom uh that are there to study six
skilled sharks the biggest deep sea
shark out there
and uh they already have a
some fish down there and a tube filled
with chum and we're just playing the
waiting game hoping for these sharks to
show up we've already seen two of them
and we're hoping that another one shows
up
and uh yeah you excited
yeah
very excited
we've been up for a couple hours so bear
with us uh and meet our awesome rv
pilots
hi i'm olaf
and i'm you and boston
we've also got one of our sub pilots
over here i am uh buck taylor did you
forget your name
it's been a long night
[Laughter]
so sharks are nocturnal and so is the
crew of the ocean explorer for the next
couple days
and uh yeah it's taking a toll be honest
with you
um but right now there are two subs down
and there are three people in each of
them and uh they are hoping to see these
six skills because they are conducting
uh not only a ambitious filmmaking
project to film these sharks their
natural habitat they're also trying to
tag them so
their goal is to attach
two different kinds of tags to the six
little sharks here to
learn about their
vertical migration or distribution
how they spend their time they want to
know what they're up to they want to
know um
how climate change is impacting them
they want to know uh what they're eating
and just like what they're doing with
their time who doesn't want to know
these sharks are awesome of course we
want to know what they're doing
yeah
anything else you want to say about the
sharks no you've taken everything out of
my mouth
[Laughter]
these sharks are super cool they can
grow up to 20 feet long they can get as
big as great white sharks
they haven't changed much since they
shared the planet with dinosaurs
they have like really cool eyes they
have like a really small dorsal fins
like way in the back of their body
they're not like your typical shark
and um they're kind of the kings down
here their only predators are each other
and queens hey we're seeing females
they're the queens
um and yeah the subs have had a lot of
luck seeing these sharks over the past
couple days and they've even like bumped
into the sub uh so yeah there's been
some fun
shark activity
and uh we're hoping to see some more
here right now we're just looking like a
bunch of horse mackerel and uh we saw an
eel earlier
so just keep your eyes stuck to
the feed and you might see something
neat
you know if you like fish then you came
to the right place
uh we are on the condor seamount which
is a protected sea mount here in the
azores which is 800 miles off the coast
of portugal it's an island archipelago
and
the reason we come here is there a ton
of these sharks uh
fishing for these sharks here
was banned uh several years ago and this
particular seamount is protected so the
population here is just thriving
and it's no coincidence that every night
these subs have been down they've seen
one
it's a sign of a really healthy
ecosystem overall here when there's a
bunch of top predators
it just speaks volumes about uh the
health of the entire ecosystem
yeah it's fun to see i'm having a great
time
definitely not tired at all
guys down there are playing the waiting
game that's for sure um
the people in the sub have been down
there for
quite some time uh but they brought some
snacks to keep them entertained and uh
fed so that's good
yeah we've got the two subs nadir and
neptune neptune's a science sub
um so we have two scientists on border
and pilot and then nadir is our filming
sub we have a director cameraman and a
pilot
and so you can't see nadir at the moment
she's in the dark hiding out of the way
and
i've been
piloting the last few nights i'm
out tonight but just to see those sharks
you've spent a lot of time the last few
days just to do it
every night
cruise buying cruising is it's
impressive it's amazing i mean it really
is like
looking at a dinosaur essentially just a
dinosaur of the deep um
coming in bottom left bottom left oh
here she goes
slow moving but so powerful wow
they get the most out of themselves so
this is a 12 meter wide sub come on so
come on
so now baby come on the sub that uh the
shark is in front of us the sign stuff
so there is uh
two spheres uh spear guns mounted on the
top that are armed with uh tags which is
how they're trying to attack these
sharks
this shark didn't get quite in range but
look how huge it is the sub is like 12
feet across since you can kind of see my
perspective how big this shark is now
that tube on the sea floor is 1.8 meters
long yeah
and so what the scientists are waiting
for we have two green lasers that shine
out from the sub and they're in line
with the two spear guns and they're
waiting for that to go just below their
doors or just below the sort of lateral
line or above the lateral line in into
the sort of muscle there so there's it's
tough for the guys you know moving the
sub around quickly and so
they have to sit and wait and shark come
back
come on wow
and so they're very patient these guys
they'll just sit and wait and get the
perfect hours and hours
we run out of snacks we cry
and you've been in that sub it weighs
eight tons
when they want to move the sub they'll
move the sub weren't they yeah yeah oh
100 i mean put their nose underneath
there just push you around
it's it's a bit funny how easy
these sharks move on coming back around
what's up what's up from the bottom no
wait where is it
it's just underneath oh it's underneath
the sharks have been doing this every
night
and start circling around and gradually
hone in and work out where the bait is
so it disappeared
it's it's underneath us it's just
underneath us
no it's disappeared you guys sucked it
up do you remember how i said that
you're gonna do like alien abduction
stuff you alien abducted the shark
so um if you're just tuning in we just
saw
we just saw six field shark and uh we
are watching uh this again oh come on
baby incoming here we go get closer
get closer
so they can't just tag the shark
anywhere it has to be in the perfect uh
like
spot on its back
oh come on here oh oh this is looking
like oh no
come on she turns turned to the turn
turn turn turn
she's going to go to the bait bar and
there's fish on the baby
nose
oh she is getting a real show right now
so the three guys in the sub they'll
just boop the sub yeah
oh my god
oh that's a [ __ ]
okay just go off i guess
to give you an idea of size that's
that's four meters wow yeah four meters
wow that was such a dramatic
shot just now size for them isn't it
sorry 20 feet it's about max size for
them wow that that we know of yeah so on
average they're um yeah they get a
little bit bigger than that but yeah
yeah wow oh turn around
it's all about that scent oh you can see
your eye yeah wow those eyes are amazing
they just roll around in their head oh
my goodness
beautiful shark so the
the tags are trying to attach this shark
um will allow scientists to here she
goes oh
come on baby girl
come on yes come on
now so the problem is we have to she's
just teasing the cell place that bait
but i think there's a bag of fish blood
in that corner
her nose is very very good she knows
exactly where that is well imagine being
in the sub right now they're really
getting it's it's pretty cool experience
we've we've had that it's pretty amazing
them getting that close and
she got it
that's it we're never seeing that bag
again
before we go though
it's well protected she can't get hold
of it
i don't think she's done with us yet a
little bit of a tease but we do leave
leave some behind that well then
normally we'll pick bits off the bar
what a beautiful fish wow
yeah
come on she can't get enough yeah
and they've been doing this every night
they get come in they have a snare for
nibble then they'll pull away again it
might get spooked with all lights and
they'll just cruise back in again
great work with the rov guys we're
getting so lucky with this right now
huge shark
really just you know so interested in
debate you must have uh really stabbed
it up good
yes
she's just kind of amazing on the edge
of the lights
but yeah scientists want to oh what's
going on
she's going to come in from there she's
turning no it's the same same one she's
just turning yeah
so yeah scientists want to attach a tag
to this shark um
put a camera tag and a satellite tag on
these sharks
allow them to see what they're doing
where they're spending their time
what they're eating
all kinds of things that um
we have not really been able to study
because of how inaccessible these sharks
are how important are they into the
ecosystem
data waste truck expert no you've been
doing a great job um
well they're the apex predator down here
so um
having them in such healthy numbers
really just speaks volumes about how
healthy the ecosystem is oh yes um
there's some nozzles that's another
yeah we've also seen the last couple of
nights when you get more than one shark
at the same time the big sharks they're
very dominant and the small ones will
disappear quite quickly and it's very
obvious when a larger shark comes into
the area because they just scan person
the only predators these sharks have are
each other so if you're a smaller sixth
skill a big six skill is like kind of
scary
very sus yeah
um
but yeah they're uh
mostly scavengers is that correct
yeah yeah yeah so they they are ambush
predators um they do
scavenge they're opportunistic
so i would imagine that helps keep
because i'm pretty healthy too
yeah yeah definitely
hard to sex from this angle but we've
been seeing mostly females haven't we
yeah yeah we've pretty much seen why
we have no idea i mean one of the things
about deep sea sharks it is hard to
study them and so being able to get to
do so from a sub is
something that we're very privileged to
be able to do
come back
getting to see them in situ or getting
to see them in their environment like
this is a really cool rare opportunity
so yeah we don't really know that much
about their population structures and
dynamics
there's a lot of unanswered questions
about these sharks which is why it's so
important to have uh scientists
uh studying them like this it's a
real treat for science
to have uh rovs and submarines at their
disposal the local scientists here that
are working with uh ocean explorer um
they're pretty stoked to be honest
uh getting tags on these kind of sharks
before was
less than ideal they would catch them at
death and pull them off the surface
protecting them and
the experience kind of messed with their
behavior for
several days and uh it's it was
traumatic for the sharks to be able to
attempt to tag them down here and
observe them down here uh is a really
special opportunity for scientists
i know they can come back around
what's
or
there somewhere
out in the gloom
and we've also got the the other sub the
filming subs on the left hand side of
this scene
she sat there with all the lights on
she gets a much better view as well
because she can look out into the dark
and see what's going on
and so um
the stuff down here are not just trying
to do science there's a
uh like buck was saying as a media sub
so uh that sub is going to give people a
really unprecedented look at these
sharks and
they've never really been filmed like
this before
um they've just spent so much time down
here over the past couple days filming
them
in different locations around the azores
and that's a treat for people who tune
into natural geographic channel
too
in the future
if you stumble upon us while scrolling
absentmindedly what up we're watching
sharks
lucky you you came at the best time
there's two sharks
uh circling these submarines
and uh you've probably never seen a
droplets before so it's like don't keep
trolling just keep watching
unless you hate fish and sharks then
just please
by all means
and they're not that scary really no
beautiful not scary
sharks are friends aren't they also
called cow sharks
these sharks yeah see like
cute name cute sharks
what's not to love
you're a shark expert yourself why am i
here
you don't take much i'm just what do you
call a shark stand
big fan of the sharks
screaming is that the shark alarm yeah
perfect code red on the shark alarm
come on baby
so welcome to my ted talk where i talk
about shark claspers aka shark penises
that is how you can tell
whether a shark is a female or a male
they basically have um two extensions of
their pelvic fins which are the fins uh
beneath their body and yeah um and so
you have two of them because there are
two pelvic fins uh and that they're
sharp penises there you go uh i did
literally a geniuses i want them penises
maybe yes
all right moving on
we keep it classy here now anyway girls
don't have those so let's get out that's
how we can tell whether they're boys
have two girls don't have any mm-hmm
right
girls do tend to be bigger yes this is
why they are the queens of the ocean
down here we saw one a a couple of days
ago and she was so white
so yes
you know be great to be able to do an
ultrasound to see if she had pups inside
yeah she
there's some big sharks here absolutely
gorgeous and it's really interesting
because the subs are about eight tons
yep yep eight tons and these sharks can
bump them and move them like
nothing so that tells you how strong
they are nose underneath the quick flick
of the tail and yeah pretty much
yeah
must be fun for those in the cell
incoming yeah
there we go baby yeah just about all
right coming from the left-hand side
there she is
here we go
yeah
hey girl hey she turns now onto the bait
this will be a great tagging opportunity
come on 10 10 10. come on baby girl
she's thinking about it
come on come on come on girl
this could be better to get it no
you tease
she's like nah forget it
she's smart
and you have to be so careful with those
triggers and not get trigger happy and
it's it's so frustrating because you
could see the lasers coming out of the
shot but you know you need to it's the
right you've got to get it in the
perfect spot
right place so it's safe for the shark
and you know the tags gonna stay on so
they only really have like one shot that
can't reload
uh oh too well for each tag yeah
but there's no reloading down there
they've come back up and it takes hours
to come back up and reload everything oh
we're pretty good hour and a half now
that's true i know that's how long it
took last
trust me i was there i know how long
if you're just tuning in um we just saw
a six field shark and it was so awesome
and we're hoping she comes back she's
like the size of the sub
um
and yeah we're here in the azores we are
uh how deep are we 231 meters 231 meters
down
um
which is hardly as deep as these sharks
can go they can go how do you
700.
over a thousand feet deep
these sharks hang out super deep um and
scientists think they come up to the
shallower waters to feed um but there's
lots of unanswered questions about these
sharks because they're very mysterious
they're very hard to study because they
spend so much time in the deep and that
is why we have a submersible down here
trying to tag them and answer these
questions
and like just you know check out cool
sharks because who would like to do that
you clearly do you're tuning into this
so
hey
welcome to the party
three people there's three people in
each cell yeah so the science one has
two scientists and uh
and a pilot and the media one has a
director camera person and a pilot as
well so
no and it's probably the media subs down
there we're creating an arena so we have
the rov up above
the neptune which is science sub with
the lights on that you can see there and
then the media sub nadir to the port
side now she's completely blacked out so
the sharks
and they will tend to ignore her
and so we're creating this arena of
light the sharks are coming in we've got
the bait there so they cruise in they
get the scent
and we've placed that
based on experience so that we you know
try and get them to line up in front of
the uh the tagging devices and we can
get those tags in
but now it's the waiting game
if you're thinking that the people in
the subs have the best jobs in the world
you're right they do
thanks
but don't tell my boss
but these are over rov boys are quite
lucky as well because they're yeah
they're the same thing i was going to
say
[Laughter]
yeah but do you want to explain uh how
the bathroom works in the sub bathroom
okay we can do liquids um but we're not
very good at solids so just bear in mind
when you come in um
it's not very discreet if you imagine
three of you in
an acrylic sphere with a internal
um
dimension of two meters cameras
everywhere cameras everywhere you hold
up a little towel for a little bit
you know discretion
to be discreet there but we have these
things called travel johns and they're
unisex and they turn urine into
i would say it's meant to smell nice but
i would say acceptable smelling
gel oh
yes so you can then handle it in a
semi-hygienic way
um but yes
it's funny though we you know
eight to ten hours in the sub people
think oh my god what do you
what do you do
and i tell people to stay hydrated the
chemical reaction to take out the carbon
dioxide because you're in a sealed unit
actually dehydrates you
and so
you can come out with a headache so if
you just treat it as you know normal
days
you know sat here
drink normally
and it's a time machine
you jump in for a seven
seven hour dive and it
goes like a flash wow it really does so
and hopefully we're going to get you in
next couple of days i hope so
that would be good yeah get some shark
action
would literally die
right come on sharks
keep seeing shadows but it's just the uh
smaller fish casting big shadows down
there
there's still plenty of bait down there
that's why the fish are still circling
so close so
there's good enough reason for the
sharks to come back
yeah and although those fish along the
bay tube are eating our bait they're
actually stirring it up so they're
they're doing a good job to send that
the fish and
blood into the water column and get it
out there as a scent trail
and um
compared to the past couple days like
this is not even that many fish there's
been swarms of fish surrounding the subs
the past couple nights like so much that
they could barely see through them to
find a shark
yeah
olaf explain what it does to your
instruments you know when you've got
that many fish in your
um well we have a
altimeter on the bottom of the dvl on
the bottom of the rv and if the fish
swim underneath it just like tend to
give us a false return on the acoustics
so it uh can push the rv off into a
different direction if we're in station
keep or give us a false return on the
altitude
which then can kick us up or down
yes
i get shouted
[Laughter]
everybody thinks of an rv as quite a
small vehicle but
uh imagine a minivan coming at you at
20 miles an hour and you're sat on the
bottom of the seabed in this delicate
little plastic sphere
and you know that olaf and ewen are
upstairs with big smiles on their faces
it adds to the excitement anyway
are we stop
stop stop stop
and the bag is full
so where are these sharks come on yeah
sharks giving us a little tease um
if you missed it before there were two
huge sharks we're not bluffing they were
here
um so we're just playing the waiting
game
and keeping an eye out for anything else
that wants to show up the uh past couple
nights random animals have shown up like
there's a mola mola just hanging out
uh which was quite a sight to see a deaf
and um
yeah i want to see some more sharks
though because uh
they're kind of what what's popping down
here yeah
i think the most amazing scene this week
was
i was sat in the media sub filming
looking up seeing the other sub and the
rov which is
pretty amazing anyway
and you get this whole arena and as you
say the molar molar just gliding in and
then a six skill underneath and you have
to pinch yourself because it's just
completely unreal that's so cool
it's absolutely amazing
we're in a special place here yeah
really yeah
um yeah it's no coincidence that there's
so much awesome life here the
protections for this particular seamount
the condorcea mount and the surrounding
waters are really good
and so when you protect marine
ecosystems this is what you get tons of
fish tons of sharks uh perfect balance
sometimes so many fish that you can't
see the sharks but that's fine because
that's what we want to see
when we're not filming we prefer it that
way yeah yeah even if it makes filming a
little more difficult very often we'll
get to see max and all you'll find is
very little life and just fishing gear
everywhere on the bottom and it's just
it is soul-destroying and litter yeah
pick up your litter plastic and yeah
it's whereas this is
amazing yeah it's beautiful
worth staying up late for
yeah
definitely
so what yeah those guys will be uh
probably getting into the the chocolate
stash by now
they've had their
evening meal which kirsty and the girls
would have prepared
but they'll get be getting fired into
the chocolate and
playing the waiting game how good is the
meal on board
the subs how good is the meal it's great
that's amazing
the uh people who go in the subs bring
plenty of snacks
uh because they'll they're done for a
while and uh yeah watching sharks eat
chum i guess makes you hungry it's not
the healthiest environment because you
just sit there and eat food all day and
don't actually move very much
all right just need those sharks to pick
up on the centro
once you zoom in on the uh
sea floor a little bit we can talk about
the corals
is that possible
these whip corals yeah
we can just zoom in on that so yeah if
you see um those long thin strands
coming from the seabed those are whip
corals and then the yellow ones i
believe are sea fans they're there's a
purple sponge down there somewhere i
lost track of it but like you guys are i
have your eyes on the screen find it
right
oh yeah
and don't worry about what you see with
the plastic drum and the plastic tube
everything we take down we bring back up
again
and very often we'll bring trash back up
with us if we see it and
we've got space to put it on the subs or
the rov so yeah
we generally bring back more than we
take down
the rovs and the subs have mechanical
arms that they can use to pick stuff up
and pass stuff to each other
which is very funny to see honestly can
you give us a wave with your arm i can
give you a wave with the arms oh yeah
try not to scratch the camera without
scratching the camera
maybe we should bring the camera lens
camera in a little bit
see jamie's going to shout at me now for
suggesting that because he's uh well we
just need to respect it we just need to
retract it on its tray a little bit yeah
and you know this is when the shark will
come yeah exactly
[Music]
so each of the subs have one arm each so
the rov has two arms
[Music]
okay
that's the you can hear in the
background the two subs talking
um to each other and then we can talk to
them in mission control and then we also
have a tracking system so we know where
the two subs are
we know where the rov is and
follow all the different assets around
this seabed
what's that
what are we looking for zoom in center
hold on there's like a oh maybe it's
gone it was like a very long fish
it's just uh made my eyes just like
tricky
um so we're coming up towards the end of
our uh
time together
so if you stumbled upon this thanks for
watching and uh if you appreciate sharks
and fish as much as we do then you're
really cool we should hang out
and ewing's just gonna give us a little
wave with his own does that mean it's a
goodbye
[Laughter]
bye
[Music]